[Music]
portland maine is where bryce joins us
bryce how can we help
hey ken and ken and george i appreciate
you guys taking my call you bet what's
up so uh i bought a new car in july of
2021
um i'm 18 still living at home with my
parents
and i have around 20 000 left on that
auto loan my question is i also
do some reselling on the side with uh
sneakers so i have around eighteen
thousand dollars
uh worth of collectible nike and jordan
shoes hold on hold on whoa whoa slow
down i wanna roll past that you got a
real shoe guy on the line with you with
me and the air jordans i mean are these
vintage are these like newer what
explain this to me
so i i don't have many vintage ones i
have more of the
like newer collaborations yeah um
so i my the question was do i sell them
now
and continue or pay it off in full
or do i let them build in value
um and continue to make the regular
payments so so are you sell are you
collecting these or are you reselling
so i do a bit of both so basically i'll
try to get two or three pairs if i can
sell one um pay off
the pair that i currently have um so i
can kind of keep one and sell one and
make my money so i basically pay off the
one that i'm holding on to are you
buying these shoes with cash uh no i i
use a
credit card oh he whispered
okay bryce i like this kid i think
you're a real bright guy whispered it
you have an entrepreneurial spirit
clearly you're really good at this
but this thing is going to bite you in
the butt
if you're not careful yeah in fact i got
a question on that george bryce of the
sneakers that you say are 18 000.
are you carrying any debt on that 18 000
worth of sneakers no debt so right now
you have 18 000
in value or liquid value of shoes tennis
shoes
correct and you owe 20 on the car
yes what kind of car is it
uh it's a honda civic
okay oh george honda civic guys this is
in your lane here all right bryce
here's here's two options one you sell
your entire shoe collection yeah that
hurts right
yeah would you even be willing to do
that you called us asking but are you
willing
well i i would if if if i got you know
if i heard the right um
i i need some some opinions that's what
i'm talking about let me ask you an
honest question why all of a sudden do
you care about paying off debt
um
i'm just set up
i don't really like to carry
debt you know i always pay my credit
cards off early when i can
i never make the minimum payment i
always pay them off in full i just don't
like debt so would you agree that
becoming debt free is the best thing you
can do for bryce right now at 18 years
old
yeah okay now george we're going to pop
corn in and out here i got to know how
much is the how much is the car worth
the civic
um
it's
newer or in the condition it's in right
now
right now it's only about it's a 2021.
you said you bought it in the summer of
2021 you've been drag racing or what
what's the deal no no no no
no what is it worth today i know i'm
kidding what is it worth today if you
sold it today
probably
i locally i could probably get around 24
25 and dude you know what i'd sell that
i'm selling the car and driving a beater
and keeping the shoe collection you're
18 you live with your parents that's
george is right because here's the other
question i had
do you want to stay in the sneaker
business i mean are you do you know
enough about it i i know i i know the
market very well i do this you know i
i've been doing the sneakers since 15
to now but i i've been mainly doing um
retail stuff so you don't want it
so you don't want to do it long term
no no if i can make a quick buck i will
but let me ask you this not something
how much of the 18 000 shoe collection
because you said part of it is you flip
them for some money the other part is
true collector so i'm going to engage
your collector's heart i'm just curious
how give me a round number because you
may not have thought through this how
many do you really want to keep if
you're going to sell some but others you
go i really want to hold on to these
just for
truly being a collector and letting them
go up in value from years and years from
now you got a number i have i have i
have around three pairs that i i
absolutely really don't want to let go
right how much are those people know
them
currently each of those are worth around
2
000 each so 6 grand
right all right george all right bryce
i'm gonna hand you to george george i
got an idea what if he sells every other
shoe
all right except those three which would
be about 12 grand he's gonna net 12.
okay he sells the car
he thinks it's worth 25. let's say he's
right he owes 20. now he's got 17. and
he's debt-free and he cuts the credit
card so he sells the car for 25. sells
it for 25.
five on the car
plus the 12. that's seven plus he's got
17 cash and you can get a better car
than a beater okay but much better than
a beater and here's what i know about no
debt he can he could get this collection
back up and go into no time
i mean if a 15 year old can do this 18
year old bryce is even better at it now
george tell him why the credit cards is
stupid bryce you play with snakes you're
going to get bit and you're a sharp dude
you don't need to do this with debt you
told me right now that you don't even
like carrying debt so wide mess with it
when you have the cash then you're it's
pure profit at that point if you're
buying selling shoes
right and same with your car you're
making payments on something that's
going down in value a car loan is one of
the stupidest decisions when it comes to
debt you could make and the truth is i
think you're an amazing amazing bright
young dude and you're gonna crush it for
the rest of your life if you can avoid
debt
which i know you can bryce you can do it
with cash also three pairs of shoes were
six thousand dollars yeah whatever
that's what my last car cost me again
george what are the shoes by the way
what are the shoes
the three pair
oh oh so
so the the three pairs i have a pair of
um
off-white air force ones the university
gold pair that released in boston
and two pairs of travis scott jordan
ones and those are each worth two grand
each
about that and the size of yes what size
you got by the way i'm just curious
asking for a phrase
um this might be the first time someone
makes a deal live on the ramsay show
oh yeah no i'm not gonna pay you two
grand for a pair of tennis shoes man
oh we can work something out of trouble
oh
i am interested in the off-white air
force ones we'll uh talk about it
hurts my brain does it hurt you what
happens if travis scott does something
stupid and all of a sudden the shoes are
worth zero because no one wants to be
associated with them well that's why i
didn't ask about the travis scott once
that's you make a very good point why
bryce but michael jordan's michael
jordan baby sure air force ones are air
force once that's true all right real
quick before we let you go young man
you're 18. what do you have an idea what
you want to do you dreaming about
something
no i i i'm not i'm not too sure right
now honestly are you in high school
still
no i graduated uh in in 21. are you
taking a gap year
i'm not sure about college right now
good man
all right hang on the line i'm gonna
give you two things all right uh we're
gonna give you the get clear career
assessment so 20 minute online
assessment all right and it's going to
help you get some real clarity on some
great ideas but more importantly a
purpose statement based on your talent
things you do best passion work you love
to do and mission results you want to
create and i'm also going to give you my
best selling book from paycheck to
purpose think of the
get clear career assessment bryce as a
compass
and the book is kind of the guide up the
mountain hang on the line we're going to
give you both of those so kelly will
give him an assessment get clear career
assessment and the book from paycheck to
purpose boy he's one of those kids that
if he really listens to you on this
whole debt thing
he's going to be wildly successful
because he has the foundation he's got
the principles down of how to do
business yeah now we just have to do it
without debt so he's not calling back
going hey i'm 200 000 in debt yeah
because i thought i was going to make a
huge profit off this get rich quick
scheme yeah kelly ask him what the ken
coleman deal would be for the off-white
air force ones we'll see
uh we'll see during the commercial break
we'll see i think it's a little high
price for me george i don't think it's
in the envelope for this one would you
look cool in them i don't know i think i
would well i'll let kelly decide that oh